this is the giant propeller advanced sl0
first for the manufacturer giant has
remoulded its famed TCR into a
full-fledged aero bike for the 2013
racing season instead of their
well-known compact geometry they've
employed a straight top to airfoil tube
shapes brakes modeled off of team only
straight full systems and integrated
cabling and bar stem systems had to
further improve aerodynamics the bike
comes fully equipped with and improved
Shimano di2 and Giants own 50 millimeter
PSLRA
carbon rims although you'll likely see
pro riders on another set of wheels this
is not a climbing bike so look forward
in the flat sprinter stages of the tour
starting now it's a spendy bike worth it
if you're riding in the flats all day or
just happen to have an extra 10k laying
around